there's one Bell on that side and
there's one Bell on the side we rush up
and we ding-ding-ding but the first one
who rushes up hey welcome back gamers to
Minecraft welcome back to Europe all the
it rings this is what life is like here
[Music]
let's go can you sleep okay sorry sorry
look look dude what you feed your dog I
found him it was hidden in the desert
were you being a little desert scamp it
happened
hey do you have a fight what do you know
but I mean I mean meaning to wait okay
come here
you wash muck hey stop come back you
have to learn how to be cool be cool
stop noticing how do you know I don't
know there's nothing I haven't done
anything Jack what did you do nothing
nothing nothing
let me just cook my potatoes in peace
all right they sleep under sport
I said Fox smart you have to put a
diamond in this warp eight Jack we have
a small pit now
[Laughter]
folks no forbidden language good
emeralds that we're dropping in diamonds
always okay okay
goodbye timeand you were like father to
me Oh God bye-bye hey door Hey look how
epic Maya
my dog is oh oh no it isn't look how
much cooler - damn it it doesn't work he
doesn't know don't judge him come on
Maya ho show ads done - is depressed
it's kind of creepy because they don't
they don't even look left or right -
just spoke frozen in time epic wait I
have more glass let me try that again
come on wake up come on he was enraged
by the better though I'm gonna pull you
see moving he's sitting dude you can't
move him if he's sitting everything yeah
ah he ones back yes understandable go n
go dump me down I wish him I give you
permission to push my don't you ever
piss my dog off here you go eat potato
in my defense he went in the hole for
like two seconds okay we're cool is he
still mad I think it's still now he's
cool he's got shirt I see my smokes a
lot God why am i spending so much time
on this cuz it's gonna be awesome
Oh
okay why don't I just push him in there
you go
okay now it'll work he's still listening
to it whatever you know let people do
what they want you know what maybe just
smoked a lot of it before and now he has
to listen to it it's not all about your
mouth it's all about your okay you
should grab some hay cuz we're gonna
head out and do what we hate forgot hey
hey yes and do what we forgot to do last
episode let's find some horses Jack oh
wait I don't even have a pickaxe hold on
pickaxe or horse well in case we get
stuck on an epic adventure you know
I need iron furs iron I don't know where
anything is this goddamn house maybe in
the mineral section don't ever swore
that was a swore wasn't it okay I'm
ready let's go let's go let's go we go
sorry my video got to monetize YouTube
life let's go gamers my tribe matters
more it never stops one gets see
monetize but record this one in a way
that it won't know story make sure so
far so good
I think I've seen I'll look there's
horses here that's so cool oh that's
epic
what is this chest oh there's a chest
what and it's so natural in the wild wow
wow it's just growing around all this
grass baby
[Applause]
Sorry Sorry Sorry
it was not me I see more efforts going
to you spent so long learning how to
minecraft and this is what you use it
for oh look jack horses wow we found
them ah small that gunpowder when you
die in Minecraft I'm getting a white
horse I don't and I want to know why it
fine alright says says I've been
pranking you epically oh look I get
blonde [ __ ] blonde [ __ ]
long story do chores dated how do you
tame them again I forgot oh you need
nothing in your hand first I think oh
yeah oh yeah that's what I was confused
by like why there you go alright team
gets gamer reward first the same gets
gamer of Year award no no I can do it oh
come on alright oh no it it oh my god he
loved me more I said yes before jump
over ravine first look look
now we have our horses we can go epic
places oh and our Cowboys
we're Elijah way different Vikings we
graduated it's great chicken yeah we
should kill chickens good I had a whole
thing in my series where I threw away a
chicken's eggs and then you found a
chicken out in the water randomly
continues oh look there's our old camp
here we should sleep sleeping in these
beds wait
it's like old beds that we had snakes me
sleep sleep this is nice
[Music]
what happened what happened what did you
do without a jack I'm asleep sleeping oh
why don't you sleep sleeping this is not
the nether why did I explore all the way
back at the first base again no oh great
all my gear is gone cool that's awesome
no I'm leaving man I'm going I'm leaving
I can't sleep there's no second bed
anymore okay where are we go well we
should bring our horses back too so they
don't get hurt
oh I'm gonna die again dude Oh God back
to pyramid Oh God so many back to
shining beacon I also did swore a second
time to put another one in the chair no
it's okay either supporting you to
notice either you have to say swore
otherwise it doesn't count ah ooh no
rules got it it was exactly he's
listening in the other ear now he needs
stereo weed okay we should I'm sorry
I'll get you new gear I'm sorry it's
okay it's part of the fun man I have a
surprise for you and not a bad surprise
this time if you follow me hmm I don't
believe you yes I swore wait I mean I I
don't swore but I'm sure now you have to
do it okay I'll drop it raw chicken how
about that Thanks okay you did you
wouldn't kill a child would you all
right follow me Jay okay where are we
going
epic adventure so for some reason I
decided to make this room like a hidden
room for no reason whatsoever
whoa but what you'll find in is a chair
take a seat right that takes it yes yes
jack you better start doing something or
I'm gonna start hitting things
okay jack we're gonna play God we're
gonna play a game day there could be
positive outcomes in this game there
could also be very bad things happening
what can I get potato if I win yes
that's the game it's potato you lose but
either way
potato potato that's it wait can I have
food now because I have a half a heart
okay fine you get one potato for me kill
you that's a great price I'm gonna ask
you some very difficult minecraft trivia
if you get it right and you're gonna
treat if you get it wrong oh okay we
just look my eyes a little okay stretch
it out around ready hit me Christ in
number one aha
what does your favorite block in
Minecraft
um oh god pressure what is my favorite
so our city in Sun I did I'm sitting not
a slore obsidian yeah look at me hey
pass the first but there's more
questions yeah keep eating what are
creepers afraid of cats very well Jack
very well doing good so far what can
make an Enderman God keep you that's it
didn't keep you two options what a
potato to a pumpkin potato absolutely
potatoes
it didn't matter what the other answer
was going to be it's always you got it
right this they're like The Three
Stooges I've a feeling our Austin's
supposed to survive though potato is
valid answer yes okay look my chair has
wings okay next question what is a
charged creeper oh no a a creeper best
running right action be the creeper
that's been struck by lightning see a
creeper that paid for everyone's dinner
I'm gonna have to go away obvious answer
number B what is that a creeper that's
been hit by lightning
oh well potatoes would rain come on man
I'm a veteran at this point questions
dude everyone knows how tall is a gas in
blocks
aim for Block B three block
one blow it's gotta be four blocks right
[Laughter]
great you could say it back into fire
how many people play Minecraft every
month 112 million a 55 million be six
million see 50 million D 10 none of
those are the right answer why you go go
they talked about it recently and it's
like 112 million people well this one
says 55 million for nothing okay in
Minecraft right there
how many blocks in the nether is one
block a in the real world eight eight
eight eight eight okay Oh
back in chair its back okay stop stop
stop okay
damnit no I need good questions you
thought those are good questions
okay hold on hold on oh oh I'll get
something okay this is a Minecraft quiz
hard no not hard
what is the rarest or in Minecraft the
rarest or what's an or cold cold do you
want to hear the options yes lapis
lazuli emerald gold or a cold gold
Oh No are you serious god this crazy
every person is after me get back here
oh the horses can't sleep sleep man
when did you replace it with water this
is why you said don't come over this way
the original I'm able to sound like
llama draw from dammit what original
idea was to have like lava to drop I'm
super high so I built this giant power
of redstone and it took so long to like
get the redstone up there and then I
burned down half the house by accident
and I was just like God and then I
changed my mind
unfortunately so many epic potatoes this
way potatoes over here jack what
potatoes we have next to do sleep sleeps
again
hey Jay oh alright boy you see this
hi-yah I prefer eyes I eat ice iii's now
it's cool those mine cry more like mind
cracked I think the end of drag is just
gonna kill himself at this point because
it's taking so long
okay what's the what's the next thing
should we I guess we never kill any
Enderman because like we need to find a
fortress
and we also need ya magma when you turn
to the nether I think it's time to go
through the nether and try and find
another castle that's true we haven't
done that yet
ya should bring some cobblestone with us
yeah do that
what was your dog doing I'm worried
about your dog my dogs holding it in his
paw being like it was so hard dude hey
hey hello might not say anything yeah
I'll put down a piston ok wait there's a
little work with me in Crouch wait damn
it oh wait let me show you something
what are you showing me no no Gordon
don't go there forbidden I I didn't see
anything
I didn't see what was down there in the
chest
you'd think you wouldn't run anymore
soon as I see a trap door and make
baking I'm trying to make a fast loot
but I am too so I click in and this is
literally me trying to use redstone like
how does that never work where you break
it ok with the trapdoor as well are you
ready yeah alright we should go to the
nether ok it's not like we actually went
through the medic ok so this is our
actual nether cause I fixed it basically
before we remember you used to take us
back all right but I'm an explorative a
brain on you
thanks to YouTube comments for once
what's the trick to finding fortresses
go straight till we find one or or we go
in opposite direction
oh that might work double double whammy
wait which way are we facing yours the
south the mine's north okay bye-bye
first it's me guess one swore out of the
swear jar well I'll see you in lava
resting lava I think you're supposed to
go like a hundred blocks north or south
and if you don't find one then go east
or west is that it's like the best way
of covering the most ground 100 blocks
okay I'm up for challenges you want to
go bro
who can survive on the nether for 24
hours dude if I can use a s'more that's
a lot is a lot of power it could be an
episode off before you say it though
this is the kind of stuff like I like it
I like this just digging a gold digger
ah that's my line dude I'm the one who
gets killed by lava it's all exactly ah
okay what did we yell when we see an
inner cancer sleepy BP oh man now I
really want to fight finally I'm
sacrificing the colour of my green
screen just so I can see oh oh God wait
this is an hour port well I found
another nether portal what did you find
anything else by the nether portal Oh No
what did you do what did you do nothing
here it's very good keep it that way
there's a ghast oh god just two gasps I
don't know oh my god this is our old
portal bridge damn what that's crazy
okay we shouldn't go north and south
ends because there's clearly nothing
feel like I'm finding areas that we've
been to we haven't oh oh crap crap
was it a flippin no I
the gas like came low and I was almost
able to hit it with my sword he flew
away like a coward crash he is unless
you flip your baby I don't hear about it
well you haven't tried to pursue
Malaysian citizen tea after 50 million
outros my etch down just down it's still
relevant just down a bit
why is the dog in the nether wait wait
that's your actual dog over there are
you telling me that the dog back in our
world is a fake
[Laughter]
[Music]
you got replaced by a 40 remember how I
had to fix the nether right yeah well he
walked through and I could be bothered
to make a not me to my only I could
control can only be one my
I understand the bridge no I could never
do it
are we smoking smoking come come come
come come I made a terrible lapse of
judge varella's judgement save my smoked
fat one here Photoshop shop followed
bridge there you go
what you gonna do now I'm so tired I
don't know why I'm terrorizing this poor
duck people are screaming push me off or
was ya cuz you left them here that's
fair I think I owe a diamond in this
world are for this okay I have a leash
on me
oh you made it nice
[Music]
they're on the warpath dude oh god oh
god oh I did this I have to fight for
glory great thighs stinky man
stinky Irish potato man stinky Pickers
this is so sad he got you final time big
boy effort melanin chat faking Maya who
hasn't moved an inch I understand that
way I was trolling to get him kill and
you got him actual kill not that big
I've made a continuous oh my god real
Maya who would never die to pig never
it's okay we have backup Maya home it's
okay I save him in cloud
well I'm sorry shut something's gonna
weird yeah it's gonna haunt you I'm
partly to blame oh really
[Laughter]
we made it through all of that I hid the
square thing and the sweep of my skit
one I would never attack Pigman I think
this mean I can kill your dog correct
you tried to kill my dog already after
No my dog is the only one who can smoke
properly we have to build grave for Maya
who and bravery yes only solution what
should we make
let's make polished poopoo block
okay it's the only way from gold people
saying okay I mean it wasn't Jurgen okay
we can't do that what did he like
another ranked lost make it automated
never blocks yeah yeah that makes the
most sense he's acting nether like good
boy waiting said waiting for father to
return can't believe he just left him
there
I didn't mean to you left him there and
then I really he's there forever did you
go what are you building this I'm just
making some new items do seconds and I'm
there okay we should make it next to my
app or maybe here right here maybe here
maybe we should sleep sleep sleep sleep
have I hit 10 hours and I have okay I
will change it [ __ ] and now we're and a
half left okay when you hit the hours
that mean you have 10 hours hour ten
I've done 10 hours and 30 minutes
damn mmm-maybe here yes done okay we
should all say something okay we are
here today to mourn the loss of my
something Maya who Maya who is there was
Maya my dawgs Maya who yours is Maya
Heat
Oh Maya Hey I loved him it was like an
eighth of spend to me eight out of swim
I did not know my he for very long but
in heart I miss him already
I I stand here now I cannot watch you
kisses me waiting for bees update you
deserve a thousand bees upon you for
what you did I'm so sorry I will have to
whip you tie me to bench hit mo break I
will hit you with whip ten times top of
morning it makes sad Irish noises now
where were you today it happened I was
here